[Musique]
la situation effectivement les critiques
elle est très pratique le gouvernement
fait des mauvais choix dès le départ il
ya aujourd'hui nous payons les
conséquences ils ont fait le choix
d'ouvrir les frontières avec cinq ou six
porteurs au pas au jour et avec
effectivement des gens non vacciner et
de vacciner
aujourd'hui nous nous trouvons dans une
situation où il y à
un conflit entre les autochtones et les
personnes qui arrivent
qui se disent vacciner mais qui ne
prennent pas de précautions depuis des
années on a détruit le services publics
de santé et aujourd'hui on en paye les
conséquences
[Musique]